et pour finir sur une note du rôle en
cette période de fin d'année si vous
voulez profiter pour rire de bon coeur
et passé une très bonne soirée je vous
conseille justement [ __ ] de soirée
c'est un peu vulgaire c'est au théâtre
du gymnase comme titre mais c'est du
grand boulevard avec un trio darry cowl
anémone patrick chesnais pas le temps de
reprendre son souffle
reportage claude crespo frédéric de la
rue une ambulance dans le salon des
choses il faut un gars toutes les
minutes
une intrigue qui tient de l'histoire de
foot et pour jouer tous à une ribambelle
d'acteurs délicieux ans domine patrick
chesnais darry cowl et anémone pourtant
il n'a pas changé
même s'il a perdu son bégaiement il
adore toujours fait courir ses doigts
sur les touches d'un piano darry cowl
est un épicurien
pour qui la vie est toujours belle
j'aime m'amuser mois donc ma bonne
humeur
j'espère et comique communicative et et
que j'aime faire rire je ne fais rire et
j'aime que les gens soient heureux
autour de moi c'est puis j'ai vu ma
naissance
mais je crois qu'elle est à deux foetus
déjà jeu j'aimais fait rien nous des
amendes de vous et moi même ses
partenaires succombe vous voyez d'où les
toilettes fait des bas si vous n'êtes
pas du tout mon genre je crains c'est
presque sans être un grand devin sont
leurs a compris c'est une comédie
loufoque
quant à l'histoire disons que patrick
chesnais est dans une situation
catastrophique en particulier un ami de
lionel messi ce soir je suis difficile à
prendre après divorce et ses espèces de
wii 2 jeu de jeu total est que public un
jeu bon enfant c'est un jeune premier
degré c'est mais on attendait dans la
lah représente c'est le plaisir pour le
plaisir quoi à cesser le
on est emmené dans le boulevard
à fond at-on aux acteurs sur scène comme
une équipe de football
mais ici c'est le public gagne tous les
soirs sans appel mais avec rappel